sorry I got my own self of course I
thought this beanie made me look hi guys
welcome to Saturday eree this week it is
my diary vlog of all the things that
I've done this week so far here's
something good boy yeah this is rough
this is the face of someone who just put
together a goddamn IKEA patio set and
now I'm in like building mode and goose
is really hot it's sweaty and gross dog
sweat just breathing like she's hot so I
decided that maybe today's the day I got
her this preemptively
before she came back home and we might
try and use it today it's a splash where
is it splash about dog pool goose is
more interested in the mop um for dogs
look that dogs having fun splashing so
let's try and set this up for goose and
tsunamis
[Music]
okay its full about three inches max she
is in a box
oh that's the patio thing I put together
yep
okay good oh it's good it's good
don't try this she is tempted
[Music]
and you're just freaking it instantly
it's just drinking all of the water
oh and then this happened
all right bye for now okay now I'm
vlogging oh man Hannah and I are here
and what looks like a creepy building
but we are assured that on the inside
are people we know and trust we are
recording some vocals for I don't know
if I can tell you that so if that was
bleeped out right I will know whether I
that should have gotten bleeped or not
so if it was down that means I can't
tell you but if it wasn't how cool is
that guys so many Mamet remember when
this happened to me
just going back to doggy camp with their
friends while her owner goes on a book
tour this one you're gonna go see your
friend
so excited hello I'm disgusting I just
went for a job just giving you an update
goose just got dropped off at daycare /
boarding dog camp school training
facility shelter I am leaving
Thursday to start book tour endeavours
which is really exciting I'm gonna be
away for like a month which is a bummer
cause I'm gonna miss that dog but she
loves the place that she is boarding it
so nice shirt there is a reporter from
the New York Times coming over to
interview me for the New York Times in
relation to the book as part of the near
Times I'm gonna clean my person and my
house as much as possible and light as
many candles as possible to diffuse the
scent of dogs there's a faint scent of
dog [ __ ] in the house and I don't know
where it's coming from
mamrie is coming over after and we're
gonna do a live stream for hey USA which
the if you don't know that's mamrie nice
travel series that we did all summer
long and the full episodes are up on the
scene calm I'm sweaty and gross I'm
doing this whole let's exercise and not
drink for a while before going on tour
to stay healthy
see I'm pretending to be a grown-up too
I took my own advice when I sweat like
this really makes I face it like it's
made up clay look oh we're here is
shooting the livestream with you guys
look there's you guys right there we're
doing a livestream for hey USA memories
getting her camera out now and now you
guys are all in friary say hey don't
blink you look great say me remember
when you did the thing that is this just
that Devils here we're here at this
green room with
Oh No okay we're not in a therapy
session I swear even though this not
since I've become angel that was like
four years it's Wednesday and we're
shooting the video portion of the audio
thing that we recorded the other day
still don't really want to give you too
many spoilers though you can probably
figure it out based on the fact that
you're off the CIA agents really they're
geniuses and I hope that you honed that
genius into a passion that improves your
life
yay okay so I have hair makeup done but
I cannot tell you who I am yet any aces
not Emma Watson pretty good impression
huh watch
really good I learned a lot from this
thing you're about to see from me me
mm-hmm mm-hmm it all makes sense
good evening it is right now 1:30 a.m.
back from the big epic shoot that
happened all day today
and now and you can see packing because
I get a car to the airport in 7 hours
and I go to New York to start my book
tour if you guys want to come to any as
a book event you can find out exactly
where and when they are going to great
subscribe books - calm and Hannah made
me recommend we're doing some no filter
shows I just ordered the costumes that
memory and Hannah and I wearing for the
note fill the shoes so stupid they've it
fits this might be my favorite costume
we've worn yet and we've worn tuxedo
onesies and pencil questions
party up top it'll fit on the bottom
like they always say in Jersey Oh me
classically doing me things like this me
[Music]
[Music]
what they go there are some of the
things that I have done this week I am
in New York City right now and tomorrow
Sunday will be my first book signing
session here in New York and really
excited if you go to great use guide
book calm you can see you are all the
book events are happening and if you are
able to come to them that would be so
great because I'm gonna use my hands and
sign books and use my mouth to talk to
use my brain to relate to this human
being I don't know
have I announced this yet no but I'll
announce it right now mamrie and I are
doing some live comedy shows mostly in
the south eastern region of the United
States all the links or the shows are
down below and I'm sorry that there's so
many things to promote right now there's
a lot of [ __ ] things to promote the
full episodes of hey USA our travel
series have gone up on how you set the
scene calm so check that out and this is
stupid
um I'm selling sweatshirts now limited
edition I don't know sweatshirts they're
really gender-neutral I think they're
super cute they're really gonna be nice
and soft and fun and cute for you for
the wintertime or your friends or
whatever represent calm slash it's grace
to number two put the number two in
there if you like these videos don't
forget to subscribe because it really
means a lot to me to see your love
quantified in numbers
[Music]
[Music]